Good morning.
It's Nog Aeration Day,
happy inauguration day to everyone.
And I,
I thought,
um,
that actually the inauguration of Barack Obama today,
uh,
and the particular lecture in this class are very well suited to one another
because although you see that the title of today's lecture technology is
technology and revolution in Roman art,
I could also call it something like the change the Romans believed in because
the change the Romans believed in the change the Romans believed in was a shift
from what we've called traditional Roman architecture to innovative Roman
architecture.
And that's what we're going to be talking about today,
what we call innovative and what we'll call in the course of this semester,
innovative Roman architecture.
We've already talked about what we've called traditional Roman architecture and
I just want to look again with you to begin today.
Uh,
with the Temple of Port Tunis that we looked at last time,
the Temple of Port Tunis in Rome near the Tiber river.
Uh,
a temple that was put up in the late second,
early first century BC.
And we talked about the fact that this was a traditional Roman building.
Of This Day to traditional Roman building,
though that was quite derivative,
that looked back at Greek architecture,
Greek religious architecture,
and to trust skin religious architecture and drew from both of those two
elements,
from both of those and combined them together into what we termed a new Roman
creation.
At least in the traditional vein.
We talked about the fact that the,
the Etruscan elements of this particular monument where it's tall podium,
where it's deep porch,
where the freestanding columns in that porch were the single staircase and the,
uh,
the emphasis on the facade that having that single staircase achieved.
Uh,
we also talked about the fact that while there were columns all around the
structure,
which is actually a Greek,
uh,
Greek,
way of doing things,
that those columns where we're attached or engaged into the wall,
which still gave it a certain sense of flatness,
including on the back,
that was also characteristic of a trust in architecture.
We also talked about the Greek elements that were incorporated here,
and those included the fact that the building was made out of stone.
Uh,
and also the fact that one of the traditional Greek orders in this case,
the ionic order,
uh,
was used for the structure.
So this bringing together of Greek and a trust can elements in this thoroughly a
Roman building.
Uh,
but a building that again,
we would call a traditional Roman building.
And what do I mean by traditional?
All the traditional Roman building share in common,
the following features,
they have columns and they have walls.
And those columns walls serve a structural purpose and that is to hold up the
flat or the sloping ceiling,
uh,
and that the sloping roof and that is in fact exactly what you see here.
But at this very same time and the second century BC and into the first century
BC,
we begin to see a new kind of experimentation that is going on concurrently with
this,
uh,
and experimentation that grows up and some of the same towns,
that we see traditional buildings like this.
And what this,
what made this experimentation different than anything that had come before is
the fact that the Romans used,
uh,
for these buildings at completely new material.
And that material is concrete.
We talked about the fact that already in the temple of poor Tunis,
concrete was used,
but concrete was used only in the podium.
You can't see it.
It is inside the podium and serves to strengthen concrete,
has an indoor,
a great deal of strength and can sustain great weights.
And so it was placed in the podium for utilitarian purposes so that it could
help to support the temple that was located on top.
But again,
none of it's expressive possibilities were explored by the designer of the
Temple of Port Tunis or any of the other temples we looked at last time.
But what begins to happen also in the course of the second and fourth centuries
BC is architects beginning to realize that this new,
uh,
concrete technology has an opportunity to transform a Roman architecture and
they begin to experiment with that transformation in order to understand the
concrete buildings that we're going to be looking at this morning,
which are absolutely fascinating.
And I hope you'll be as a,
as enthralled by them as I am.
And they again stand at the very beginning of this development of,
of uh,
innovative architecture in Rome.
It's important to know a bit about concrete Roman concrete that is a,
and I want to make a few points about it.
Roman concrete,
the,
the Latin term forward,
his opus [inaudible] mentee them as I've indicated here,
Roman concrete is different from what we think of today as concrete.
It's a composite of various natural elements that becomes a liquid mass when
mixed with water and eventually hardens into a very,
very strong substance,
much stronger than any of its ingredients are on their own.
Roman concrete was a mixture of stone rubble and liquid mortar and composed of
lime sand and something called Putz Solana Pot Solana being a volcanic
substance,
which was very plentiful in Italy,
especially around the area of uh,
Pompei Herculaneum.
The area of Campania concrete was used in Rome from the early second century BC
on,
but it was not until the end of the second century and the beginning of the
first century that the expressive possibilities of concrete began to be fully
realized.
Concrete.
I think this is also important to mention when you think about concrete
construction,
uh,
in relationship to a stone construction that we've already discussed.
A concrete is not cut or quarried the way stone is.
A concrete is cast in molds.
Concrete can be cast in any shape,
at least any shape that a carpenter can build with wood and like modern
builders,
the Romans erected wooden frames for their walls and ceilings and they poured
concrete into those wooden frames.
What's most important for us in the context of this lecture and in this course
in general,
is that the introduction of Roman concrete into Roman architecture freed the
Roman architect from the confines of a lack of a rectilinear architecture that
they had inherited from the Greeks.
The kind of rectilinear architecture,
uh,
that made up a temple,
like the temple of poor Tunis.
This is a very momentous change,
uh,
and one that will have a lasting impact on the buildings of the Romans.
Let me try to give you a sense of what I mean by this.
One could argue that the greatest,
a concrete structure built by the Romans was the pantheon.
And I remind you of the Pantheon on the right,
in fact,
the Dome of the Pantheon,
which would not have been possible without concrete construction.
But it's interesting to compare the Pantheon to a,
an attempt a that a trust can architects made to create something similar.
Uh,
but out of stone,
I show you on the lefthand side of the screen and the trusts can tomb that dates
to 600 BC.
Uh,
so very early in time,
600 BC and a trust skin tomb at a place called,
it's not on your monument list,
but at a place called Quinto,
Fiorentino Q.
new word,
Quinto Fiorentino in a trust can territory.
Uh,
and what the architects have done here is to try to create a round tomb.
And they've used stone as you can see,
uh,
and they have laid those stones if they've cut and quarried the stones as usual.
Uh,
they've tried to cut them in the shapes that they need in order to make this
work.
And they piled them one on top of the other,
uh,
row after row after row until they've gotten,
didn't,
didn't it started out okay at the bottom.
But if they get further and further onto the top and it gets rounder and
rounder,
uh,
and Khloe and converges at the apex,
they start to have trouble as you can see.
And although it's a heroic,
a valiant attempt on their part,
it isn't terribly successful,
at least to my mind,
aesthetically.
And in fact,
they were worried about it falling down.
So they even had to place a stone pier here,
uh,
to support the Dome to make sure that it didn't,
didn't drop.
And actually that was pretty successful because here it is still today looking,
looking pretty good in,
in that regard.
Uh,
but with the,
with the,
um,
introduction of concrete into architecture under the Romans,
building a dome like the Pantheon was simplicity itself.
All you needed to be able to do was to build one of these wooden models,
a wooden structures that you then poured concrete into a and Voila,
you have the dome of the Pantheon.
So simplicity itself,
transformational,
uh,
visa vi Roman architecture.
The only problem with concrete,
and there were two problems with concrete that the architects of this period had
to contend with.
One of them was that,
uh,
concrete,
is,
uh,
has to be protected from moisture.
That's number one.
And number two,
that concrete is less attractive than stone.
The Roman architects of the second and first centuries BC solve these two
problems in the same way.
What they decided to do was when the concrete was still wet,
they put,
they attached a stone to it.
This could either be large ashler block stone blocks or it could be a small
pieces of stone,
that uncertain worker opus and carried them that we talked about last time
pressed into the concrete when it was wet and when it all dried,
uh,
that stone both,
both made the building look more attractive,
uh,
and also protected,
the building from moisture.
We looked last time at that opus and Keratin facing,
I remind you of the temple of Vesta at Tivoli,
which you see here.
And you will recall that the temple of Vesta at Tivoli had concrete both in its
podium for utilitarian purposes and to support the great weight of the temple.
Uh,
but also that the architects explored making the seller wall,
the curved seller wall also out of concrete.
And then when that concrete was wet,
they put in these small cut irregularly shaped stones called uncertain worker
opus and character them,
uh,
to protect that.
So we saw that already in the temple of Vesta,
even though it was a traditional temple based on Greek and a trust in models.
And we'll see it again today in several buildings.
And I show you just one example,
the last structure that we'll talk to you to talk about today.
The sanctuary of Fortuna premed Jania at Palestrina and extraordinary structure
built on a hillside that also used a opus and care to them as the facing.
And you can see it used here for the wall and also the coffered ceiling above.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so a [inaudible] stone,
a stone facing opus,
and carried them.
That was particularly favored in the second centuries BC and into the first
centuries BC over time,
uh,
the choice of facing changed,
although Ashleigh blocks too far,
uh,
two for travertine and opus and character and were popular in the second and
first centuries.
As time goes on,
things change.
We'll see under the Roman Emperor Nerva,
there was a revolution,
another kind of revolution of sorts in Roman architecture.
Uh,
and we'll talk about the reasons for that and so on later in the semester.
But with that revolution came and interest in the new facing material,
namely brick brick that was originally stuccoed over.
And in fact,
the opus and Keratin work and the two FA stone that we've talked about already
today tended to be stuccoed over as well.
Uh,
but by the second century,
we begin to see an appreciation for brick in its own right.
The attractiveness of,
of brick and the Romans begin to use the exposed brick as the facing for their
buildings.
And I show you one example.
It's a detail of a warehouse.
In the Roman port city of Ostia that we'll look at later in the term with this
exposed brick facing very attractive,
different colorations and so on and so forth.
Uh,
but adjust just to alert you to the fact that again,
the kind of facing that we're talking about today will not be the only facing
that is used by the Romans.
Over time.
I want to show you today a series of these concrete constructions,
concrete experiments we might call them that begin to,
uh,
turn off,
not only in Rome itself,
but also in some of the cities close to Rome that we saw.
Rome began to colonize a in the republic and into the age of Augustus cities
that either are the same or very close to the ones that we looked at last time.
And I'll show you a map momentarily.
I just want to begin with one in Rome itself.
This is the so called porticas Amelia in Rome.
The port at this Amelia was aware house,
a very large warehouse on the banks of the Tiber river.
Uh,
the porticas Amelia,
um,
was,
uh,
built as you can see from the dates on your monument list,
very early on,
one 93 BC and then restored in 174 BC.
Only a small fragment of the porticas Amelia survives today.
But we have a lot of evidence,
a lot of clues that we can piece together through detect,
do through scholarly detective work,
uh,
to determine,
what this building looked like in antiquity.
And we can get a quite accurate sense.
We have,
for example,
the words of the Great Roman historian Livie Livie who was writing in the age of
Augustus.
He tells,
uh,
that,
um,
the,
uh,
porticas Emilia,
he describes it,
he mentioned support because Amelia and he tells us it was located on the east
bank of the Tiber River.
Uh,
and that it was a south southwest west of one of Rome,
seven hills,
the Aventine Hill,
south west of the Aventine Hill,
which is enormously helpful because it gives archeologists and so on,
a clue as to where they might look for remains of this particular structure.
So we have that.
We also have a fragment of the building we believe,
because it's located just in the right place.
And I show it to you here,
it's not much.
It's a piece to essentially a hunk of concrete,
uh,
that includes a,
an arched doorway in some arched windows,
but it's very important in terms of allowing us to reconstruct what the
structure looked like in antiquity.
Uh,
but most significant of all,
we have a fragment from what is known as the marble map of Rome.
The marble map of Rome called the Forma Orbis.
And I put that word on the monument list,
that title on the Monument List for you.
The form of Orbis.
The form Orbitz was a great marble map that was made of Rome in the early third
century.
Aidy under the emperor worship of Septimius severity and put up on a wall
enrollment.
We'll talk about its location later on in the semester,
but it purported to represent all the buildings that were standing in Rome in
the early third century,
obese in the early,
in the early third century.
Aidy uh,
it is fragmentary today,
but there are a fair number of fragments.
And fortunately a couple of those fragments are several of those fragments,
uh,
are fragments that represent the porticas Amelia.
Uh,
so we can tell from that,
from that,
from Libby's description,
from this a fragmentary remain,
we can piece together what it looked like and you can see it who are a very,
very long rectangular,
a structure that went all along the bank of the river storage.
You need a lot of storage.
Your of your,
you know,
from the,
especially with the con,
as the Romans began to conquer the world,
they were trading more extensively with other parts of the world and
consequently they needed,
um,
they needed places along the Tiber river to store the goods that we're both
going out and coming in.
So they build this gigantic warehouse,
uh,
along the banks of the Tiber.
Now there's a fair amount of disagreement about some of the smaller details of,
uh,
this,
warehouse and what it looked like in antiquity.
So we have to do the best that we can to bring that evidence together to
determine what it looked like.
But as I said,
in some details you'll see there's variations.
So several of the things I'm going to show you very slightly,
uh,
but the only one that you'll be ultimately responsible for is the one that's on
your monument lists.
But I just want you to be aware of the fact that,
uh,
that there are different,
that there are different interpretations of exactly what it looked like.
A,
what what we are sure of and what's most important for us today is that it was
made of concrete and that it had barrel vaults.
What was a barrel vault?
A barrel vault was a,
uh,
a Balt,
that was getting made out of concrete,
placed on a wall,
and then had the bolt was shaped like the side of a barrel,
as you can see here,
which is why it's called a barrel vault shape,
like the side of the barrel resting on walls down below.
A fairly simple shape,
uh,
that could not have been made or would be very difficult to make out of stone,
but was easily able to be made out of concrete.
And we see a series of those barrel vaults placed one next to another,
uh,
for the warehouse for the Portico as Emilia in Rome.
It was placed.
And actually I,
I neglected to mention live.
He also tells us that the Dickus Emilia had four tiers.
It was tiered in four levels.
Uh,
and we see those four tiers here rising up ever so slightly along the slope of
the Tiber River.
This is a cross section of what the,
uh,
inside of the Basilica Melian might have looked like.
You see those great barrel vaults here.
You see that the architect has been adventurous in the sense that he has not
placed the barrel vaults on solid wall as we saw on that diagram,
but has open those walls up,
created peers and arches above those peers to create these arcades,
uh,
which is quite ingenious,
and,
and very smart because what it does is enable there to be both axial movement
through the building,
but also lateral movement.
You can walk not all only along each barrel vault,
uh,
but you can walk in between the peers,
which is,
as I said,
creates a much more open,
a sense of much more openness,
uh,
and and lateral as well as axial movement.
The other thing that you see here is our,
the back walls where we can see just what we saw in that fragment of the
building,
the arched doorways as well as the arched windows in the back walls,
which of course allow light into the structure.
Lots of activity needed to happen here as things were moved in and out,
and those who worked here needed to be able to see everything that they were
doing.
The the view that you have on your monument list is this one.
It's a restored a view of what the porticas Emilia might've looked like in
antiquity and it's very helpful.
It's a cutaway view which gives you most of the major features all in one place.
You can see that it is indeed tier.
There are four tiers for this structure that they move up slightly as they move
up the slope of the hill.
You can see the use of the barrel vaults,
you can see the piers down below.
You can see the flat roof that these seem to have,
but as they rose up slightly along the slope of the hill,
you can see that the um,
that the designer has this small curved slit windows on each tier to allow,
again,
additional light into the structure.
And you can also see from this diagram that it was made of concrete and faced
with opus and care to them work these small,
a small irregular stones that we saw in the temple of Vesta,
also used as the facing material here.
Here's one more,
a restored view,
which shows you roughly the same.
The four tiers,
the barrel vaults,
the windows on the various tiers.
And then most importantly these,
um,
these doorways and windows in the back,
uh,
as well as the general space that was available inside this extraordinary
building.
I mentioned that while we'll look at a couple of buildings,
several buildings in Rome,
I also want to go out to some of the colonies that were founded by the Romans in
the vicinity of Rome in the second and first centuries BC.
And where they began to build.
As we saw when they began to plan towns,
they began to put walls around those towns.
They began to put temples in those towns and they also began to put other
structures including warehouses and sanctuaries and the like,
the ones that we're going to look at today,
here again,
Rome is at the star.
Uh,
and we're going to look at buildings in terror,
Cina over here in Tivoli and also in Palestrina.
And you can see the proximity of those to others we talked about last time nor
ba and Khoza.
And if a Larry Novi and so on and so forth,
it's not surprising.
Again to see the Romans turning to their environments as they make these
earliest towns and as they start to fill these towns to make them into the kind
of mini Rome's,
uh,
that they,
that they so desired.
So I'm going to,
we're going to look at a series of these,
have different dates,
uh,
and of,
um,
considerable interest in terms of what they Harold for.
Uh,
the future of Roman architecture.
The first that we're going to look at is a market hall,
a market hall at a place called Ferintino.
Uh,
Ferintino and it dates to,
I may have neglected dimension to show you very [inaudible] on that map,
but it's in with all the others there.
Verun TNO around 100 BC.
It dates to,
uh,
and you can see that it's essentially one giant barrel vault,
one giant barrel vault,
which was used as the market hall.
Uh,
the,
uh,
you can see also that that giant barrel ball,
which is made of concrete has opening off it on,
on the sides a series of arched areas with also barrel vaulted on the inside.
These were used as the market stalls inside this market place.
You can also see,
I believe very well,
uh,
that the facing that is used for this concrete is opus and care to him,
work for the walls and for the vaults.
And then what they've done to emphasize the location and the shape of the
arches.
They have used stone around those also to give further solidity to this part of
the building.
Uh,
they have,
uh,
used stone.
Uh,
and you can see it's a combination of,
uh,
nicely cut ashler blocks down here,
but also if the booze Joar blocks that we've saw in the flairy Novi Gate used
over the arches.
So this combination of both stone,
uh,
and,
of,
of uh,
Opas quadratus stone and also of opus and care to him,
uh,
used as the facing for this particular structure.
Uh,
what's significant about this building is that it looks forward,
uh,
to things that we're going to see later on develop in Roman architecture.
Primarily.
I showed you in the introductory lecture a glimpse of the markets of Trajan in
Rome.
And I remind you here of the Great Market Hall of the markets of Trajan,
which is even more sophisticated in its use of concrete because it has rib bolts
as you can see.
But this experimentation that we're going to see in the early second century,
a d in Rome would not have been possible without the experimentation and
concrete that took place,
uh,
in this very early stage in the second century.
And in the first centuries BC even more,
much more interesting in fact is the building that I'd like to turn to.
Uh,
now,
and this is the so called sanctuary of Jupiter anx or at Terror Cina.
It dates we believe to 100 to 70 BC.
And it is like so many Roman building spectacularly cited.
I had mentioned this on several occasions.
We looked at the medieval Hilltown of Corey,
for example,
where the temple of Hercules was located.
At the very apex of the hill.
The Romans had an incredible knack for choosing a extraordinary locations on
which to cite their buildings,
locations that made those buildings,
that they accentuated those buildings from a distance,
uh,
but also gave those who went to the building's amazing views out from those
buildings.
This is one of those examples,
the sanctuary of Jupiter anchor at Tara Cina.
The best view of this sanctuary is from the sea.
If you happen to be fortunate enough to be floating on a boat somewhere near
terror Cheena and it's a beautiful place to float,
uh,
you will see from a distance,
the great podium of the sanctuary of Jupiter answer,
but you can also see it from the town,
which is where we're situated here.
We're standing in the town,
couple of decent pizzerias,
uh,
right in front of us and we're looking up at the hill on which the sanctuary
finds itself.
Now as you look up to that hill,
all you can actually see is all that's actually up there now,
which is the podium of the sanctuary.
The temple is no longer there,
although there's some evidence up there,
some remains that give us a decent sense of what that temple looked like in
antiquity,
but the podium is extremely well preserved and you see it again magnificently
sited at the top of that hill.
This is a,
uh,
restored view of what the podium would have looked like and you see what we know
with the podium,
what the podium does look like as we see it here.
And as it would have supported the temple on top a and also a back,
a columnar element over here that was roofed.
As you can see,
uh,
if we look at this plan and this restored view,
excuse me,
we see several things that are worth noting.
One that the temple itself is very much a traditional,
uh,
building and one that is very much in the tradition indeed of the buildings of
the temples that we've already discussed.
This combination of,
of,
of a trust skin,
uh,
plan and of Greek elevation that we saw in so many of these.
Uh,
you can see,
for example,
they,
and again,
there's enough evidence for us to be pretty sure that this is what it looked
like.
Hi podium,
single staircase,
emphasis on the facade,
the porch freestanding columns in that porch.
Uh,
but columns that seem to have encircled the monument.
so this combination of a and stone construction,
we think,
uh,
so a combination once again of a trust can and Greek elements for the temple.
You'll probably notice that the temple is slightly skewed.
The angle of the temple is skewed.
It's not straight on with the podium,
which is very unusual for the Romans.
Will,
we'll see that the Romans were very interested in everything being exactly as it
should be.
Axial symmetrical,
both sides matching.
It's very unusual for them to skew something like this.
Why did they do it?
It probably has something to do either with something that was already on the
site,
uh,
some,
some other building that forced them to do this or having something to do with
the particular God who was honored here on the location.
You know,
the way they wanted that to be in relationship to,
uh,
various elements of the rights or a East,
west or you know,
whatever.
And it was that there was something that caused them to put this in the position
that they did.
And you can also see that it isn't,
it has this back colonnade behind it covered colonnade behind it,
but it isn't attached to it in any way,
which is also unusual as we'll see.
Uh,
the podium you see down here made up of a series of arcades and you can see once
again both axial and lateral access because just as in the poor dick is Amelia,
they have created a smaller arcades in the side peers to allow this kind of
axiology in the structure or movement through the structure in more than one
way.
The podium is extremely well preserved as you can see and extremely impressive.
It's an extraordinary place to go.
It's a lot of fun to go there to see this.
It's off the beaten track to a certain extent,
but it is on the road between a Roman Naples.
So that one,
if one is going from Rome down to palm pay,
uh,
you know,
this is the sort of thing one can stop and take a look at.
And there's some other interesting things along the way as well.
We see here the great podium as it looks today.
It's made out of concrete.
You can see both the uh,
the large arcades and then these lateral ones that I mentioned before,
uh,
in the,
interior face of the peers.
Uh,
you can also see that they have used opus and carrot him facing here.
these irregular stones all bunched together to create an attractive appearance.
Although this was probably stuck out in antiquity.
And then they have used a stone blocks to emphasize the juncture of each of
these walls,
but also to help give the building a increased stability.
So this combination of stone,
well it's all stone,
but this combination of blocks of stone and a smaller opus and carrot them
stones for the facing of the podium.
And here's a wonderful view,
I think,
uh,
that shows you a,
a panorama through a number of these lateral arches and gives you some sense of
how carefully orchestrated this was by the architect who is responsible for
this.
It's never too early for me to emphasize it.
The Romans were very concerned with creating vistas and panoramas from one part
of a building to another from one part of a complex to another.
And they never,
they never lost an opportunity to do that.
Uh,
so that as you stand and look through a series of these lateral arches,
you can see how carefully arrange that was to pay attention,
not only to the way in which the arches,
um,
yeah,
you can see them in a series a,
as you can see here,
looking almost as if they're diminishing in size,
although they aren't really,
uh,
but also this idea of creating exciting visual experiences as you walk through
something,
not just to walk through it,
but to see something,
uh,
that really,
amazing as you.
And that fascinates you and that,
that creation of Vista and Panorama,
uh,
both panorama out onto the countryside from the hilltop,
but also a panorama or vista through a building is something quintessentially
Roman.
And we'll see it turning up again and again and again in as an as a major
objective of Roman architecture.
Uh,
a view once again of the restored view of the sanctuary.
The sanctuary had below it,
uh,
a underground passageway called a crypto porticos.
And I put that word on the monument list for you,
a Crypto porticas that was used essentially for storage for storage purposes,
for,
uh,
this sanctuary.
And believe it or not,
we actually have the crip deport.
It goes still preserved and we can look at it.
And it's interesting because here too,
we see the architect's using concrete construction,
creating a barrel vaulted Carter,
uh,
in this case with windows on the end.
And then a few doorways and some slip windows.
All of them arched,
as you can see here,
to allow light into the structure.
It was used,
as I said,
for storage purposes,
a storage having to do with the cult.
Uh,
and so on and so forth.
It's very important.
We're going to look at a couple of other sanctuaries as well to keep in mind
that these sanctuaries,
uh,
meant there were different than an individual temple in a,
in a forum,
inside an urban complex.
They were meant to draw pilgrims from,
uh,
from far and wide,
which is one of the reasons that they were placed in such prominent positions on
tops of mountains that you wouldn't,
has it,
you know,
if you were dry,
even driving by if you were going by in your cart or whatever,
uh,
and,
and saw this from a distance or coming by sea in a boat,
uh,
seeing it from a distance you would be drawn,
it would be like a mecca that you would be drawn to a,
so these sanctuaries where meant to attract large numbers of people to them.
So they needed to provide not just the temple itself,
but other things.
And they often,
they were like malls.
They often included shopping areas,
souvenir shops,
a shop,
shopping in stores for a local specialties and that kind of thing.
Uh,
in order to encourage people to visit.
I'd like to turn to another also very interesting sanctuary that was put up,
uh,
at around this time.
This is the sanctuary of Hercules at Tivoli.
Uh,
and it was erected,
we believe sometime between 75 and 50 BC in Tivoli.
It is an incredible place.
It is not so different from the sanctuary of Jupiter ANC,
sir and its general intentions.
His whole idea of creating this,
uh,
this Mecca for a religious activity and also just a place that people would
enjoy coming to and gathering together.
And uh,
you know,
in for social interaction,
uh,
we see a restored view of what it looked like in antiquity.
It is similar to and different from uh,
the Jupiter Anc sir sanctuary,
just like the Jupiter angular sanctuary.
It rests on a very tall,
on a tall and large podium.
As you can see,
the temple doesn't stand in isolation,
but it's raised up on this large podium.
Uh,
you can see that it has a temple in the center.
This one completely pushed up against the back wall and completely straight.
So axial and created acts in axial relationship to the podium.
The temple we believe was also one of these traditional types of temples with
the tall podium with the staircase on one side with columns going around at
least three sides.
The porch freestanding columns in that porch raised up on,
it's all on its own podium and then the larger podium down below.
The,
one of the features that we see here that we did not see in the Jupiter Anc,
Sir Sanctuary is the use of the circular staircase here,
which adds drama to the design.
It's also on axis with the staircase of the temple itself,
but it also serves as a kind of,
it's shaped like a theater,
a theater,
a Cabi,
and we call it a copy of the seating ca VA.
The caveat of a theater,
it's shaped just like that.
As you can see here,
and we believe it's purpose was not so much as a monumental entrance way or
monumental staircase,
although it served that purpose to a certain extent,
but also as a place where people could gather and could sit and probably watch
performances.
Religious performance is perhaps or perhaps other kinds of performances in front
of this,
uh,
in front of the temple of Hercules and there may have been some kind of a stage
building.
There was a wall here,
so there may have been also some kind of stage building in front of that,
a semicircular seated area.
This is a nother,
this is another restored view showing you the same.
You can perhaps see that theatrical area better here,
again,
serving as a dramatic staircase but at the same time as a place where
performances could take place,
uh,
at this,
um,
at this structure.
But all the other features are a parent and I want you to pay a special
attention,
special attention to the fact that we have the temple pushed up against the back
wall,
not one of the short back walls,
but while none of them are short here but against a long back wall as you can
see,
but pushed up against it,
dominating the space in front of it.
We're going to see when we turned upon pay on Thursday that this same idea of
pushing a temple against the back wall is characteristic of forum.
The design,
the design of meeting and marketplaces as it is,
uh,
for sanctuary design.
The sanctuary of Hercules at Tivoli,
uh,
has,
um,
is,
is preserved in part.
And I can show you one very interesting detail which is what you see now on the
screen.
We are looking at part at,
at uh,
we may have been,
let me go back for a second.
Just to
point this out.
If you look at the back,
if you look at along the sides and the back,
you will see that there are columns above and then columns with art.
With arcades,
arcades and columns in the first story,
and then columns on their own in the upper story.
So what I'm going to show you now is a section of the lower story of the
sanctuary of Hercules at Tivoli.
And we can see that what we have here is it very important combination and it's
the first time we've seen this today of arches with columns intersperse columns
placed,
engaged or attached into the wall in between,
uh,
these arcades,
as you can see here,
uh,
the construction is concrete.
The facing is a combination of stone.
Look at the blocks,
the Ashler blocks and the booze wars above the arches,
uh,
and opus and character work,
for the walls as you can see here.
But this scheme of columns in between arcades extremely important.
This is,
this is,
uh,
this is setting in place the kind of scheme that we're going to see use for
buildings like the Colosseum in Rome.
So extremely important.
There's one detail here,
this one detail about the columns though.
I wonder if anyone notices that make them different than any other columns that
we've seen thus far this term.
Does anyone see what that is?
Okay.
They definitely don't.
Yes.
Good point.
I that wasn't the one I had in mind,
but you're absolutely right.
And it leads to a very,
into another point I'm going to make in the not too distant future.
They don't support anything.
They are used here.
The building is supported by the concrete construction.
Uh,
the columns don't have any support role whatsoever.
They're,
they're entirely for decorative purposes.
So excellent point.
And it's still one more.
Look at the facing of the column.
What does that tell you?
What is it?
What kind of facing
opus and care to them opus and care to them,
which means what?
The columns are made of.
Concrete.
Two columns are not made out of stone,
but the columns in this instance,
it's unusual,
but the columns in this instance made out of concrete and also faced with opus
and Keratin work.
Uh,
a view,
again of the complex,
just to make the point that as at the sanctuary of Jupiter,
anx banks are at Terra Cina.
There is an underground passageway,
a crip deport,
it goes,
uh,
but in this case,
and you can see it's on the left,
underneath the left side of the sanctuary.
But in this instance,
in this instance,
interestingly enough,
this isn't just a storage area,
it's actually a street.
The ancient name for a Tivoli was teaboard Tib you are,
there was a street called the via t Bertina that made its way from Rome to
Tivoli.
Uh,
and uh,
this,
this underground passageway was actually the street the street ran underneath
the sanctuary.
Uh,
that street or that part of the street that ran under the sanctuary can still be
seen today.
Uh,
and you can see,
uh,
it looks almost like,
you know,
an underground subway or something like that.
You can see barrel vaulted area,
uh,
with a series of niches over here probably for shops.
So that along the way you could stop and shop at the,
uh,
at beneath the sanctuary.
So,
and a street in this case that is part of the via t Bertina leading from Rome to
a Tivoli.
I'd like to turn now to a couple of buildings in Rome,
back to Rome.
Uh,
to look at first,
uh,
a building called the Tabula Laurium that dates to around 78 BC.
That was a very important building in Rome because it was used to house the
state archives at that particular juncture.
It was put up by a man.
We a know who put it up.
A man by the name of Quintess [inaudible] could tell us,
and I put his name on the monument list for you.
Uh,
and it was located on the north side of the forum of the Roman Forum and the
south slope of the capital line hail.
And here I show you one of these excellent,
uh,
Google Earth flyover views of,
this part of ancient Rome or what ancient,
what,
what this part of ancient Rome looks like today.
And we see the landmarks that we've already pointed out,
the call theme at the very top,
the Roman forum lying in front of the coliseum.
Mussolini's via day Fori Imperioli the imperial for over here,
the Palatine hill up here,
the circus maximus here,
the wedding cake,
so called a Victor Emmanuel,
the modern building,
19th century building over here.
And then the,
um,
the capitalized hill redesigned by Michelangelo with the Oval Piatsa.
The top,
you Laurium is located right here.
It is again facing the forum or the Roman Forum.
Uh,
but it is the back wall of one of Michelangelo's,
uh,
palaces,
the so called senatorial palace designed by Michelangelo.
What Michelangelo did is what was done so often by later architects.
It didn't tear down the earlier Roman Tabi Larian,
but incorporated it's wall as the back wall of his senatorial palace.
Uh,
and that's exactly what it remains today.
Here we see a view of the Tabula and we're standing on the forum side looking at
the what remains of the Tabi Laurium.
Uh,
and we can see some of the features that we've already been discussing today.
First of all,
let me point out that it is made out of concrete,
is made out of concrete building is concrete,
but here in Rome,
uh,
they decided not to use opus and carried him work was not a the rage in Rome.
Instead they were much more interested in cut stone cuts stone and you can see
that they have used a cut stone in this structure.
Cut Tufa stone I think you can recognize this,
don't as to for remember to a is indigenous to the city of Rome.
Rome has a lot of fairly decent Tufa.
They've used to fa here.
Uh,
and uh,
they have used Tufo work also for the arcades above and for the columns.
The capitols are done in Cha,
travertine added and travertine and considered the most important parts of,
they use the more expensive material there.
But you can see here as at the sanctuary of Hercules at Tivoli that we have this
combination of arcades and columns and once again is as was already pointed out,
columns that have no structural purpose whatsoever.
Columns that are there for pure decoration.
And this scheme of arcades with columns is going to come become extremely
important,
uh,
in the future.
One can go inside the top,
you Laurium today,
uh,
and see what remains of this state archives.
Uh,
there are some very interesting Carter's and vaulting that one can see.
And by the way,
it's a nice place to go because there's also a panoramic window on which one can
get some spectacular views down over the Roman forum and some great pictures as
well.
Photographs as well.
Uh,
we're looking here at one of the carters of the tabular IOM.
You can see that the arches are made out of stones supported by columns,
but in between them,
there are a series of bays as you can see here.
And in between them we have domical ceilings that are made out of concrete.
So concrete use tier combined concrete for the domes,
a combined with stone.
The Romans were very handsome stone that the Romans,
those in Rome itself favored a use for the arches and used to decorate the walls
as well.
And what's interesting is that we find in these carters,
some s a series of ramps and a series of steps,
and there's actually one staircase that has 66 steps.
I've counted them 66 steps,
uh,
as well as ramps.
And what we see happening here,
and these are again covered by barrel vaults.
What we see happening here is the Romans paying a lot of attention to varying
the experience that you have when you walk through building.
Sometimes you're going to be walking on a straight path.
Sometimes you're going to be walking on a ramp,
sometimes you're going to be walking on stairs to very that experience.
So,
and you're going to see panoramas and so on along the way to make it an
experience to go into a building and to wander around that building.
But we're also going to see,
and I'll show you this particularly in the last structure we talk about today,
we're also going to see the Romans not hesitating to be the controlling force
that they very much were.
And to establish certain predetermined paths that you have to take.
So you're having a varied experience,
but you're kind of having it in the way that the Romans want you to have it.
And that's an interesting phenomenon that I hope will think about,
uh,
together in the,
as we converse,
uh,
in the,
in the online forum.
I want to show you one last building in Rome today before I show you the,
the,
the real ps to raise this dawns of concrete architecture of,
of this early period.
I'd like to show you one more building in Rome.
It's a later building and in some respects it belongs in a later lecture.
It's the theater of Marselis and Rome.
Uh,
a theater that was put up by Rome's first emperor Augustus,
uh,
after the death of his nephew and son in law.
Marselis.
Uh,
he seems to have put it up.
That is Augustus seems to put it up.
He was great grief at the loss of this young man because he had hoped that
Marcel is,
would succeed in Marcellus,
was married to Augustus,
his daughter Julia.
You'd hope that Marcellus would succeed him,
but Marcella's unfortunately died very young.
Augustus was an incredible grief and he put up this theater in Rome,
this stone theater in Rome,
in honor of Marcellus.
The theater was put up as I mentioned,
either in 13 or in 11 BC.
So I could talk about this.
We have several lectures on Augustus and I could talk about this in that
lecture,
but I decided to put it here,
uh,
because it really is the culmination in a sense of some of the experiments we've
been talking about today.
And I wanted you to see it in this context.
For that reason,
we are looking at the theater of Marcellus as it looks today.
Uh,
parts of it are extremely well preserved.
As you can see at least these first two tiers here.
The main reason that the building has survived,
and you can see,
well,
I'll talk about the details in a moment.
The main reason that the building has survived,
and I,
I believe I mentioned this in the introductory lecture,
is that it was reused over time.
It was reused as a,
um,
as a fortress in the middle ages.
It was used as a palace in the renaissance.
And it was used as a and most recently,
and it's still being used as a very luxurious a condominium today.
This is where Google earth really comes in handy.
Uh,
you can go if you go onto Google earth because it's very difficult to get a
sense of the way in which this ancient,
the ancient part of the structure relates to the rest of the structure today,
uh,
without going up above it.
And by going up above it and looking at it both from above and,
and Google Earth now allows you to do three d at the same time.
So you can do three d and up above at the same time.
Uh,
you,
you can see the relationship of this building to its modern locale.
And by the way,
it's just in the shadow.
It's very close to the capital on hill.
It's a hop,
skip and a jump from the Capitoline hill.
Uh,
this area of Rome,
it's actually the so called Jewish ghetto area of Rome.
It served as a ghetto and in times past,
and it's still referred to it that way today.
And it has some of the best restaurants in Rome.
If you have never had Carciofi Alla Judea Jewish artichokes.
Wow.
They are incredible.
And there are several lots of restaurants in this area that has them.
They're a real,
a real Roman treat.
It's considered a part of a very characteristic part of the cuisine of ancient
Rome.
And it's definitely something to experience.
But we see the theater of Marcellus right here and you can see,
uh,
both,
the facade,
which is the ancient part of it,
but also the rest of the building and the way in which it is used today as a
condominium with apartments opening off,
uh,
these lovely courtyards with trees and plants and flowers and all sorts of,
of things there.
And there's another famous temple,
the temple of Apollo that is located right outside.
There are only three columns preserved of that temple,
but also it's podium right in front of the theater of Marcellus.
This is again Google earth.
You can look not only at what the building looks like today,
but you can recreate a,
now all of you know,
in these last couple of months,
they've enabled us to recreate ancient Rome as well.
And one can do that for all of the buildings that we'll be looking at this
semester.
And this one is their recreation.
It's fairly simple,
but their recreation of the theater of Marcellus.
And it allows us to look at some of the features of that building.
Again,
sorry that I have to talk about so much about terminology at the beginning,
but as I mentioned,
once we get through this the first couple of weeks,
we won't have to do much of that anymore.
Uh,
but the basic components of a Roman theater where the seating,
which is called the coffee,
I see Ava,
which is this,
um,
semicircular seating that we see here.
The coffee is usually divided into a series of wedge-shaped sections,
which you cannot see here.
But I'll show you in another view in a moment.
Wedge-Shaped sections that are called each year called the Coonass,
c u n e u s a coonass.
And then there is a stage building.
We're seeing the back of that here,
but a stage building facing the seating,
uh,
called a scan I fronds,
Sca,
e n.
A.
D e.
Skein I fronds.
Uh,
what's important to us here in the context of this lecture is that wild,
the Greeks built their theaters and Greek theaters were the base with a main,
um,
prototype for Roman theaters while the Greeks built their theaters on hillsides.
Uh,
the Roman Roman's.
We're not content,
uh,
as a,
as an urban,
as,
uh,
as a,
a civilization that was interested primarily in urban centers.
The Romans were not content to build their,
their theaters on hills.
They didn't want to be constrained by having to build their theaters with hills
happen to be.
And so now with concrete construction,
what,
what they were able to do instead was to build a hill out of concrete anywhere
they wanted to build a hill out of concrete,
right in the center of downtown Rome.
And then hollow,
uh,
that concrete out in order to create the entrances and exits from that
structure.
And that's exactly what they did for the theater of Marcellus.
If we look at this detail of the outside of the theater of Marcellus,
we will see that this building made out of concrete is like the others we've
talked about today,
faced with uh,
some kind of stone.
In this case,
the stone is travertine.
The decision of Augustus was to get this more expensive stone,
bring it from,
from uh,
from a Tivoli and use it for this structure,
uh,
blocks of stone,
Ashleigh blocks of stone as you can see here.
And interspersing among the arcades,
uh,
columns,
columns that was as we're well pointed out before,
have no structural purpose whatsoever.
Columns that served only as decoration and the fact that they were decoration,
uh,
is,
is a parent in the fact that they have a varied the orders.
Here we see the doric order use for the first story and the ionic order use for
the second story.
And we think there may have been a third story today.
What you see up there is part of the later construction.
Uh,
but if there was a third story,
whether that had columns or Pilasters,
which you'll remember a flat columns if it had those,
those were probably of the Corinthian order because that is exactly the scheme
that we see on the later coliseum.
Doric ionic and ultimately Corinthian,
but we're sure at least of the doric and the ionic.
Uh,
so these columns had no structural purpose whatsoever.
Purely decorative in a sense.
They're kind of the icing on the cake.
They don't hold up the building,
uh,
but they decorate it in a very nice way.
And it shows you that the Romans are beginning to use what the Greeks used as
structural components of their buildings,
namely columns to hold up walls,
to hold up roofs.
They are using them for purely decorative purposes,
playing around with their original purpose and using them in a different way.
And we see that happening,
uh,
in spades here.
If you go into the building,
you will see the carters,
uh,
of the,
of the theater of Marcellus.
Uh,
you will see what first looks like a barrel vault done out of concrete
construction,
resting on stone,
on travertine peers.
Uh,
but you see that that barrel vault curves,
a curving barrel vault is technically called an annular vault.
A andN ,U l a r you see an annual or volunteer or a diagram of an annular
volunteer.
It's essentially,
again,
a barrel vault that curves.
We sometimes refer to it as a ring vault because of its shape.
So you see those annular vaults used in the theater of Marcellus.
These are the same bolts that will be used ultimately in the coliseum.
A quick view of a typical Roman theater,
the theater of Marcellus in Rome,
and a typical Greek theater.
This is the famous theater at Epidaurus of the mid fourth century BC in Greece a
and I show you just wanted to point out the main differences.
They look superficially alike,
uh,
in that,
both of them have an orchestra,
they have a area of seats,
they have a stage building.
Uh,
but there are some important differences.
One is,
and you can't see that over here,
but the Greek theater had a round orchestra.
The Roman theater always has a semicircular orchestra.
Both of them have seats.
The Kavya here you can see these wedge shapes,
sections of seats,
seats called the Coonass,
uh,
that both Greek theaters and also Roman theaters had both of them have stage
buildings.
All of the stage building is more prominent in the Roman context,
but the most important distinction is the one I've already drawn.
And that is,
as you can see it Epidaurus the Greeks build their theaters on hilltops.
You can see the trees and part of the hill very clearly here.
The Romans build theirs on hills,
made out of concrete,
not always.
There are some exceptions to that and we do have some Roman theaters built on
hills when the hill happened to be in a good location and and particularly
beautifully sited a,
but for the most part Romans build them on their own concrete construction.
I've mentioned the monument of Victor Emmanuel,
the Victoriano.
And I just wanted to say a couple more words about it because,
and you'll see how it fits into the context here in a moment.
Uh,
because it's a 19th century building and it's a building that was put up to
honor the first king of the Kingdom of Italy.
Uh,
his name was Victor Emmanuel,
the first Victor Manual,
the first,
it was put up in 1885.
Uh,
and you see it here,
get a major landmark in the city.
This is a Google earth image once again,
but the reason I show it to you in this context today is that it is in a sense,
terrorist on the slope of the capital line.
Hail.
You'll see Michelangelo's oval pops up,
they're slow.
It's terrorist on the slope,
a series of levels,
staircases leading to terrorist is leading to other terrorist is leading up to
the top of the building,
decorated with statuary.
It's a real experience to climb up it.
It's an amazing place to go.
It has the tomb of the Italian unknown soldier,
uh,
here,
and uh,
w with guards and eternal flame and all of those things.
And I must add for any of you who have not been in Rome in the last year,
uh,
and two,
we're hoping to go sometime soon or whenever in the future.
They have just added on top of the victor.
It was,
it was always a great place to climb up and see great views of Rome,
but they have just added an elevator,
a modern elevator that they've created that you can now take up taking you even
higher than you were ever able to go before.
The views of Rome from there are among the most spectacular that one can see in
the city.
So I happened,
unfortunately when I was there this past June,
it was raining and it doesn't rain in Rome that often at that time of year,
but it was a,
so many of the pictures that I took,
um,
are,
you know,
sort of do this sort of gray background and so on and so forth.
But nonetheless,
it some of the most spectacular views you can you see of the city.
So don't miss out on that opportunity.
But I show it to you in this context because of all of this terracing up a hill.
The idea for this kind of thing goes way back to the second century BC,
uh,
and comes from buildings like this one.
This is without any question.
The masterpiece of Roman concrete architecture,
concrete construction,
sanctuary design,
uh,
in the second and first centuries BC,
we're not absolutely sure of its date for a long time is by the way,
the sanctuary of Fortuna Prima Jania at a town called Palestrina.
The date is very controversial.
Uh,
there are many who long associated it with the Roman General Sola and said that
it dated to ADBC.
Uh,
there's,
there are others who have contended that it's much earlier than that updates to
the second century BC.
And if it dates to the second century BC,
it's even more amazing because that means it comes at the beginning rather than
at the end of this second and first century BC development.
Uh,
I tend to now,
I've gone back and forth.
I taught it as a solid building for quite a while now.
I've been teaching it last few years is a second century building.
It probably doesn't matter all that much a dates to one or the other and it's an
example of what was going on at that particular time.
Uh,
but I'm,
I'm giving you a date,
uh,
this year as a second century BC,
which I think at this juncture is probably my personal opinion is that's
probably where it belongs.
A,
you're looking at it here.
It is an incredible,
it is part of an incredible Hilltown just like Corey.
Uh,
the city of,
um,
Palestrina is a beautiful hill town.
Uh,
you can see it here with all the wonderful,
the red roofs of the town that tie the,
the design of the town together.
Uh,
the culminating monument of that town is still the sanctuary of Fortuna Prima
Jania at once again,
the Romans have found a spectacular locale for this sanctuary.
Come theater,
come shopping mall,
a Mecca for Romans,
uh,
of its day on this hillside.
They have a,
once again,
they have in fact taken over the entire hillside.
They have terrorist the hillside as we can,
as we can see.
And they've essentially poured concrete on that hillside to create a system of
ramps and stairways.
And with the temple at the very apex,
it is pretty well preserved today.
You can see there's an awful lot of,
it's still there.
Uh,
you can either,
if you're coming by car,
you can either park down here or up there,
uh,
and you can make your way up the ramps up the staircase to the various levels.
And then up to the theatrical entrance,
way into the upper most part.
This is the temple of for tuna herself,
which was at the apex and was located probably in what may have been a kind of
mountain alcove at that particular time.
Uh,
was transformed in the 17th century by the famous Barberini family.
They Miss Italian family.
Pope's came from that family and so on,
uh,
transformed into,
they were very smart to transformed into a nice little palace that they could go
and stay in when they felt like at a small palace.
But one that takes the exact shape of that upper most part of the sanctuary.
I'll show that to you in a moment.
Uh,
here's a view from Google earth.
You can see Google or it doesn't always work.
When you go out to some of the smaller places,
it's hard to zero in on it well enough to get a decent focus.
Uh,
but you can see it actually here.
You can go to Palestrina and see it on Google Earth.
Uh,
this is,
you know,
these are the,
the various tiers with the,
uh,
with the palace at the upper most part.
Here's a restored view.
It's on your monument list.
Uh,
that gives you a sense of what the building looked like in antiquity.
you can see the entrance way was down here,
a small arched entrance way,
but you really needed to go up the ramp so you could go up on either side.
Uh,
so we see this,
this,
this composite,
just like we saw at the top.
You Laurium is combination of ramps and staircases,
uh,
to make your way up,
buried experiences.
But at the same time a predetermined path,
uh,
because while you had some choice when you first arrived,
you could go up the ramp on either left and right and you can see it was a
covered ramp and antiquity.
But when you got here,
you had one choice.
You had to go up the stairway to this level.
And then there,
there some shops here you could explore.
But then if you want it to go up to the next level,
you have to go back to the central stairway,
up to this level,
back to the central stairway,
and then to the stairway in the shape of a theater at the upper most parts.
So again,
experiences stress,
your experience of the building with stress.
But at the same time,
your path was determined by the Roman designer.
This is another view of the same where we can see the entrance way,
the ramps,
the staircase leading you from one to the other,
the upper most staircase.
Here you can well see the theatrical,
uh,
the,
the way in which the theater,
the semicircular theater is used both as a,
an attractive entrance stairway to the structure,
but at the same time as a place where performances could actually take place.
Then a,
what's called a Hemi cycle.
You see several Hemi cycles here,
AGM I cyc,
l,
e,
these curved areas.
The columns follow that curve.
You see that Hemi sick send me cycle at the very top.
And then at the ultimate,
the,
at the,
at the apex of the structure,
uh,
the shrine of Fortuna tuna herself,
a small round tron.
In fact,
it's almost a,
an anticlimax to see how small the shrine at the upper most part of the
structure is.
How did the Romans achieve this?
They,
uh,
they,
they created,
as you can see here,
a series of,
they converted the hillside into a series of manmade terraces.
A,
they've built those terraces up in some instances by barrel vaults.
You can see the series of concrete barrel vaults here as they have built some
elements up along the way.
And the ultimate,
uh,
ultimate result was what you see here.
The same sort of thing we saw before,
the ramps,
the staircase,
the hemi cycles with columns supporting a curved wall,
a series of shops.
Uh,
the spectacular estate is theater like and a staircase,
the curved heavy cycle at the upper most part and then peaking up at the top,
the,
a set of the temple of four to know herself.
It's hard to conjure up in a classroom in new haven,
the actual experience that one has when one goes to Palestrina and climbs
through this structure and is not as well preserved today as it once was
obviously an antiquity.
But in the few minutes that remain,
I want to try to recapture or try to take you through that experience where
obviously and to get in to show you how arduous it actually was.
It's,
it's a,
it's a climb up there.
And in fact,
this is one of those examples in there,
many in Italy that one likes to call,
um,
uh,
stair masters made by nature essentially.
I mean places that you can go and you can,
you put an,
exert a lot of effort into to making your way to the top of this sanctuary,
the best,
the best natural stare,
a stairmaster.
And um,
Italy is of course a lot.
Any of you have been along the Amalfi coast.
You know,
there's nowhere on the Amalfi coast that you don't have to climb up and down
with multiple times a day.
Uh,
and that's exactly what's happening here.
And you can see how steep,
uh,
this path up the up the ramp was a and we're going up the ramp again,
it was covered in antiquity,
it's open to the sky today as we go along the ramp,
we see the remnants of some of the capitals.
These are,
uh,
travertine capitals as you can see here,
a fallen down.
But if you look at some of these capitals in detail,
you see something quite extraordinary.
And that is the capital isn't straight the upper most part of the capitol
slopes.
And now why is that?
The reason that is is because if you're going to put columns along the inner
wall of the ramp,
which is what they did,
the column,
the capital's have to conform,
uh,
to the,
to the incline of the,
uh,
of the ramp.
And so they have,
they have,
um,
slanted those capitals.
The whole idea though of,
of changing and the Greeks would never do something like that.
I mean,
it would be sacrilege to change the shape of a capital a,
but this Roman architect has done that with a band in here.
He needed to do it because they needed to fit it into the scheme,
although he could have not had columns there,
but he wanted to have columns there.
So he slandered them.
This,
this whole,
this,
this sort of sacrilegious approach,
uh,
to traditional Roman architecture,
traditional Greek and a trust in architecture.
The willingness to,
to change things,
to experiment told us as a change,
you believe in the willingness to change,
to change these things,
to experiment with them in ways that had never been done before.
Uh,
to go against the tenants of traditional ancient architecture,
namely that of the Greeks and a trust gives is something quintessentially Roman
and something that we see happening here.
And again,
Harold's a,
a very innovative future.
Here we see again the ramp,
we see the capital's,
the slant of the capitals and we see that the work here was done,
was concrete faced with opus and carried them both for the walls and also for
the ceilings as one makes one's way up the ramps.
We see these alcoves all of this done,
you know,
but the various shops alcoves all of it done with concrete faced with opus and
carried them.
We see the remains of the Hemi cycles.
You can see the columns made of Tufa with travertine capitals supporting this
curved attic of the Hemi cycles.
Uh,
we see the bolting a width,
it's concrete construction.
This is an annual or volt.
Once again,
uh,
where we can see the facing is in the coffers is opus and them work.
Another view of that,
both the wall and the annual or vault decorated with,
uh,
opus and carried him work at detail of that opus and carried them work to show
you how very attractive it was.
It's a pity that it was stuck over in ancient Roman times.
A view that I took.
Again,
just to give you a sense of how steep the climb is,
you've made it up the ramp.
Now you're at that central staircase,
you're on your way up.
It's very,
very steep.
The,
the stairways,
stairways are pretty narrow,
pretty,
uh,
you know,
are short so that it's a very arduous trip up as I said.
And then you can get a sense of the fact that you would have seen the sanctuary
of fourtune at the top.
Now you see the embracing arms of the Barberini Palace,
but you can see those arms follow the exact shape of the original hemi cycle
that was once there.
And you can also see the theater staircase very well preserved.
And I show you a detail of that,
the inner staircase leading into,
uh,
the,
doorway into the museum today.
And just in closing a return to the,
uh,
restored view of the structure itself with the sanctuary of,
um,
with the temple or the shrine of Fortuna at the very apex,
the shrine that unfortunately no longer survives.
But I think as you look at this last view of this monument,
uh,
you can see that what the architects have created through this terrorist thing
through pouring concrete on this spectacular hillside is a kind of a pyramid,
a kind of a pyramid with the,
uh,
with the goddess at the apex of pyramid that I would contend a was more
extraordinary through what the Romans did with concrete,
uh,
than what nature itself had provided in the form of this mountain.
And it gives you an incredible sense of what the Romans were capable of doing in
the second and first centuries.
BC Visa VI concrete architecture experiments that again,
are going to have a lasting impact on,
uh,
the architecture that we'll be studying in the course of this term.
Thank you.